each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available so we'll uh we'll continue
with our discussion on uh logistic
regression we'll talk about Connections
um and then we'll Branch off into svms
and we'll talk about svms
today so let's start uh with our with
our basic uh usual thing you given data
so given X1 y1 up
to XM ym so you given some labeled
data and uh what you're going to do is
U so you're going to model P of Y
condition on X and Theta you're going to
write this
as being proportional to P of theta
product of P of
Yi condition on x i and Theta so you're
just going to make this standard I idea
assumption and this is how things look
like right so you have this this part we
have seen multiple times in the past so
this is nothing should be surprising to
you so we can uh now take a negative log
likelihood which is what we are
interested in because
um we already know that this is if you
work with exponential families then this
quantity is going to be convex right
so this can be written as minus log of P
of theta minus summation going from 1 to
M of the log of P of y i condition on X
right so this part we have seen multiple
times there's nothing new happening
still and what we are going to do in
particular is we're going to assume this
to be an isotropic gosan right
so what that means is that if you take
the minus log of P of theta then you'll
just get 1 12 Norm square right so this
is going to be the log of P of theta
okay so this is just an arbitrary
choice and you can choose other priors
and if you choose other priors you can
get other uh uh other instan other kind
of regularizers right so we discussed
this a little bit before so if you if
you use a laas prior then you'll get a
L1 regularizer if you use a gosan prior
you'll get an L2 regularizer you can in
general use an LP regularizer or you can
also use a u conjugate prior okay so but
we are not uh we are not looking at
conjugate PRI we just going to stick
with isotropic G okay just for this is
just a choice and then for this P of Yi
condition on X sin Theta I'm going to
choose an conditional exponential family
okay so again this you have seen before
P of Y condition on X and Theta I'm
going to write this as x 5 of XY * Theta
minus G of theta condition on X and
where G of theta condition on X is the
log of the sum over y of
X+ y of
XY okay so this this is all familiar
make sense okay so if I use this as my
as my uh P for p of Y condition on X I
then this uh can be written as plus
summation of G of theta condition on x i
minus 5 of x i y
i time
thet and again I going from one to M
okay and this is my objective function
so let me just call this G it okay so so
far nothing is new I haven't done
anything that we have not done before
okay so up to this point it's exactly
the same as what we have done
before and then what we are going to do
is because this is a negative log
likelihood we're going to minimize this
right and some of the things that prati
talked about last time some of these
methods can be used so for instance if
you know how to compute the gradient and
if you know how to compute the hesan if
you knew just the gradient you could use
gradient descent or some related method
if you're using the Hessian then you can
talk we can talk about using Newton
method and so on okay but uh we'll if
there's more interest we'll come back
and talk more about optimization but for
now let me let me work on interpreting
this and showing you some some neat
things about this okay so any questions
about this development so far any
anybody have doubts okay so now let's
first do the simple uh the simplest
possible development that we can do out
of here which is let us specialize by
assuming that the Yi are going to come
from + one minus one okay so this is our
specialization for binary logistic
regression okay and I want to show you
how the specialization works and also
how this is related to the logistic laws
and and also I also want to show you I
promised you that I'll show you how it
is related to n base okay so how n Bas
and logistic regression are very closely
related they're not they're not very
different from each other although some
people would like you to believe they
are okay so let us start with this right
so let's let's start with the simple
assumption that the Y belongs to + one
minus one so if this is the case what
happens to our uh log partition function
so let us look at this guy first okay so
how does the log partition function look
like the log partition function in this
case looks like G of theta condition on
X looks like log of x of five of
X and + one time Theta
okay
plus
X+ 5 of
x - 1 *
Theta okay so this is just from the
definition this is the log of the sum of
X puff over all possible values of Y now
I have restricted y to be just + one
minus one so I just substitute it in
here and I get this quantity okay so
this is what happens and therefore what
can I do if I look at this if I ask what
is the P of Y = +1 condition on X and
Theta if I if I look for this how does
it look like this looks like X
of 5 of
x + 1 * Theta okay divided
by
X+ 5
x +
1 *
theta
plus
X+ 5 x -
1 clear because there are only two
possible cases right y can be either
plus one or minus one so my normalizer
is the log some X if I have the if I
have the X of the log this those two
cancel and I'm just left with x and x so
I get x + x okay and clearly you can see
this is
a density right because it sums to one
okay so so in analogous way you can
write if you substitute plus one for
minus one you can write the same thing
okay this I'm going to rewrite in a
slightly uh different way so I'm just
going to divide numerator and
denominator by this quantity okay if I
divide numerator and denominator by this
quantity the this becomes 1 / 1+ and
what happens here this is x^ 5 of
x - 1 - 5 of x + 1
* okay do you see
that if I just divide the top and bottom
by the same five of x * f i of x + 1
okay then this is what happens
okay and now I'm going to just rename
this quantity because see this is just 5
of x - 1us 5 of x + 1 so it's always uh
it only depends on X right so if you
tell me X you have told me everything
about it so I'm just going to rename
this as F hat of X okay so now what
happens this is nothing but 1 / 1
+
x f hat of x *
Theta
okay and what is this
function this is the logistic function
right this is exactly the loss this is
you remember when prep introduced you
logistic regression probably he went
this route right so he showed you that
let us assume that P of Y condition on X
and Theta looks like this right we
didn't do that assumption we said let's
start with an proper exponential family
treatment okay and then from an
exponential family treatment let us
make this restricted to + one minus one
then this is how it looks like okay and
actually in fact you can verify for
yourself this is not easy to uh this is
not hard to do you can verify that P of
y equal min-1 condition on X and Theta
can be written as 1 / 1 + x of minus f
of x * th and this is not very hard to
do you just have minus1 here divide by
minus1 you'll get exactly the same thing
it's not very hard so I can combine the
two and basically write the two as
follows right so I can say p of Y
condition on X and Theta is nothing but
1 / 1 +
x y * f of x
* okay and this is the this is probably
from where uh when pradep started he
probably Started From Here Right saying
let us assume that there is a logistic
function there's a logistic transfer
function right so we have an X you take
some feature you multiply it with Theta
take multiply it with Y and this you
apply the logistic transfer function and
that will give you the uh output that is
between 0 and one okay so this is like
applying a sigma transfer function on
top of a do product
okay but here we didn't have to do any
of that we started from the exponential
families and we directly derived this
quantity for us okay now why is this uh
why is this interesting so let's now try
to play around a little bit more with
this and try to understand more about
why this kind of interpretation is
somewhat more powerful than just
applying the logistic transform okay
so first let me show you uh what happens
to
the
let's first try to understand what
happens to the prediction how do you
predict in such a setting right once you
have a proper probabilistic
interpretation the the advantage is that
you can go ahead and actually make these
natural ask these natural questions and
answer them quite well right which is
you can say how am I going to predict so
you remember in this setting we said
whenever we find a Theta after we find a
Theta the prediction is simply going to
be
arax of P of Y condition on X and th
right so if you give me an X what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say How
likely is each of these labels among
these labels set I'm going to pick the
one which is the most likely and predict
with that right so if I have a
multiclass I mean if I have
a lot of classes to choose from I'll
find out what is the probability
conditional probability of each of these
classes and then I'll choose the one
which has the most probability okay in
this case for our case we only have two
classes right so it is either + one or
minus one so you can say therefore you
can say We'll predict P of Y if P of y =
+ 1 condition on X and Theta is bigger
than P of Y = -1 condition on X and
Theta then you predict + 1 otherwise you
predict minus one okay so because we
only have two classes you only have to
consider two probabilities okay so you
just have to say what it's basically
like a you know like a similar to a
burol distribution right because you
just have two
possibilities or equivalently I can
write this as this
right okay now has changed or even uh I
can do the following thing I can take
the log on both
sides and do this okay now what is the
log of P of Y = +1 or P of Y = minus1 we
know P of Y has this form if you use
this here what
happens the P of y = + 1 over P of Y =
-1 you just have to do the math it will
will just turn out to be F hat of x *
Theta this is not very hard to see
because if you think about it you have f
of x f of x i y i * Theta minus G of
theta but G of theta is common in both
so G of theta cancels out and then
you're just left with 5 of
x uh iy I * Theta over 5 of x i y i *
Theta so the
both within the exponential and then you
take the log so you get this you can
verify this this is again just algebraic
manipulation so what is our prediction
rule therefore our prediction rule is if
this
quantity if F hat of x * Theta is bigger
than zero then predict + one otherwise
predict minus one okay this is our Rule
now I want to show you how this
prediction rule rule or how in general
this this uh prediction that we do in
logistic regression is related to what
we are doing in
Naas okay so so far everybody happy any
questions about any of this manipulation
okay so now let us see what we were
doing in Naas do you remember if you
remember what we did in Naas we said
suppose you're given some words or
features right it doesn't matter we what
we are going to do is we're going to
comp compute the difference in the
conditional probabilities of those
features like for instance we were
Computing log
of P of
wi condition on y
equals
spam
minus log of P of wi condition on y
equals H do you remember we were doing
these kind of transformation so what we
said is we're going to look at each word
we'll say how How likely is this word to
occur when the email is a spam versus
How likely is it to occur when the email
is a ham and if some words have this
have this capability to distinguish a
lot more right just because they occur
more frequently in spam versus ham like
for instance vagram may occur more
frequently in spam than in h while on
the other hand common words like the
this that that and so on may not occur
with large difference in frequencies
okay and then we just simply did this
and when we had to predict on a new SE
on a new word we just did computed this
over all possible words in the document
right so we just sum this up okay when
you do the summation so now let me call
this F hat of the data X the aat feature
okay and I'm doing this deliberately
okay so I'm saying that I'm going to
think about this as one long Vector okay
so for every word in your document what
you're going to do is you're going to
compute this quantity right and then
you're going to take the difference and
put it in here okay this gives you a
vector I'm going to call this Vector F
hat of X so this is nothing but the aat
component of this Vector right because
the aat word you're taking the a
component of this vector
clear and then what you're doing is to
predict you just computed this quantity
and you you said if this score was above
certain threshold you'll predict this as
spam if not you'll predict this as
H so in dotproduct terms this is what
you're doing you're Computing F hat of x
times the vector of all ones that's what
a summation means okay and then you say
if this is larger than some constant I'm
going to predict plus one otherwise I'm
going to predict minus one okay contrast
this with what is happening
here there are few key differences okay
so first of all in principle they're
exactly the same but there is one key
difference in logistic regression these
weights Theta are
learned okay in N ways these weights are
fixed okay the second thing is that in
logistic regression you have a choice to
design the F hat right you can design
the F hat in whatever way you want you
can say I'm going to I'm going to look
at remember what was our F hat was just
f of x i x y so this was you remember
our definition of I had right was 5 of
x y = + 1 - 5 of X Y = -1 right this was
our F hat the same thing is happening
here too see this is a feature of when y
equals spam this is a feature of when y
equals H and you're taking the
difference of the two and you're calling
it f hat you can do the same thing here
this is some feature of spam this is
some feature of ham and you're taking
the difference and you're calling it f
hat but here you are not restricted to
using the log probabilities of the
words you can use any feature you want
in fact you can use these log
probabilities directly if you want if
you want you can use some other feature
okay so in in terms of feature modeling
this is more this is more flexible but
even more Flex flexibility comes from
the fact that after you have defined
your features you learn the weights for
the features so what are these Theta you
think of this is the importance of each
feature suppose if Theta is 10 for given
feature and is say two for some other
feature then what this means is is that
what you have learned is that one
feature the first feature is five times
more important than the second one in a
n setting you don't have that
flexibility You're simply saying
whatever it is every feature it's like
everybody gets an equal vote okay every
word gets an equal vote so you want to
determine whether an email is Spam or
ham every single word in that email
we'll get a
vote okay and the vote is equal so it's
a very Democratic process
here every single feature gets a vote
but the vote is not equal some may be
more important which kind of makes sense
right so there may be some words which
are much more discriminative than the
others and you want to be able to
upweight them you want to be able to
give them more weight while some other
words may not be that informative and
you want to give them low weight okay so
it's it's both it depends both on the
value of the feature and the weight that
you give to
it okay and that is the connection
between Nas and logistic regression is
that clear so Nas is a very restricted
form of logistic regression where the
features are fixed and the waiting of
the features is fixed you you never
learn and that is why there is no
learning phase in logist in Naas right
so you just you just take the counts and
that's it there is no
learning okay but in logistic regression
you have to learn the thetas you have to
optimize this function and find the
optimal
Theta okay that is the difference
between the two algorithms that's the
connection and the difference between
the two so in
general you would expect that logistic
regression would per
outperform Nas given the right set of
features okay so and here because there
is a lot of um a lot of flexibility that
you have in designing features it's both
a curse and a boon so if you really have
domain knowledge right then you should
be using that to design your features
okay now one question that people
frequently ask me is like how do I
design features how do I know that you
know these are good features or how
should I design my features okay so for
that there is think of this as an
empirical rule of thumb a practical tip
is that think of this every feature as a
question about your
data okay so think of every feature as
some question about your data some
discriminating question about your data
so here you could for instance suppose
if you have text you could ask um and
you want to understand whether you know
this uh this email is Spam or ham okay
so here you can simply say okay I'm just
going to look at the words and ask for
whether they spam or ham but here for
instance you could design a feature
which says how many what fraction of the
data is capital letters versus what
fraction of the data is lowercase
letters or you could ask how many times
does a word begin with a with a proper
capital letter versus how many times the
word does not begin with a capital
letter or you could ask how many times
does a punctuation mark occur in one
data versus how many times it occurs in
the other case so these are all
questions that you can ask which have
nothing to here you're very restricted
because you have to use the features or
the words whatever they are providing
here in some sense you can design your
own features of of course it's not
saying that you cannot do exactly the
same thing here you can do pretty much
similar things here except that the the
sort of danger here is that every
feature you introduce is weighed equally
which we all know may not be true like
for instance if you know that certain
large fraction of words are capital then
that's a much more better indicator for
spam than to say okay you know certain
punctuation marks are occurring much
much more but they should not be weighed
equally but when you go to Naas they get
equal weight but in logistic regression
they'll get different
weights okay and you can also choose
this Theta flexibly by choosing a PRI so
you might say I know that I'm going to
introduce 120,000 features but most of
the features I know are not going to be
useful for prediction just like here you
may say I know that my vocabulary is
very very large I have like a 30,000
words in my vocabulary but not all words
are going to be discriminating then how
do you eliminate these features you add
an L1 penalty here and most of the
values of theta will go to zero if most
of the values of theta go to zero the
corresponding features will be lost will
not play a role okay so this is the
connection between Nas and listic
regation
clear
questions
good so now let us do one more thing
with this one more manipulation with
this let us see how does this objective
function look like for the for the case
of logistic regression for binary
classification how does the objective
function look like and I'm going to take
the gradient and try to understand
basically what does the um optimality
conditions tell me or what is it what is
it intuitively that this uh that this
algorithm is trying to do okay and then
we'll this will lead us into when we
talk about svms I'll show you again svms
can also be derived entirely from
arguments from the exponential family
okay so most people would tell you that
svms have only a geometric
interpretation there is a margin and
then the margin is being maximized and
so on I will show you that you can
actually use exactly the same kind of
argument and I can show you how the
estimators produced by spms can also be
viewed as being related to the
exponential family okay so they're very
very close intimate relationship and
that is why in
reality logistic regression andms are
much much closer than people would like
you to believe okay so they are and
that's why it's not very surprising if
you see papers they'll say oh logistic
regression did 88% accuracy svm gave me
89 or the vice versa they're very close
to each other right and the reason for
that is because they indeed are very
close they're very related although
people don't want to see it okay so but
let's let's look at this um let us look
at the objective function so in this
case the objective function for the
binary classification
becomes
12 n Theta square plus you have a you
you know that P of Y given x i Theta
looks like this so this becomes
summation
I going from 1 to M of the log of 1
+
x
of five
hat of
x * thet okay so this is how the
objective function looks like
because you see this is the this is the
objective function right so this log P
of theta is 1 12 n Theta square and the
log P of Y condition on X can be written
this
way and if you take the gradient of this
function and set it to zero so let's
take the gradient and set this gradient
to zero what happens to the gradient so
this is theta plus summation I going
from 1 to M of 1 / 1 +
x of 5 of x * Theta
times I'm just applying chain rule so
this is
X of
X there must be a y I'm missing a y here
that's
right times y * x
equals partial with respect to Theta of
J of
theta okay just just plain chain rule so
log is 1 / X and then 1 + X+ X and then
the gradient of y * F hat * Theta is y *
5 okay so just chain
R now look at this
quantity what can I rewrite it as I can
rewrite it as P of y i of course
everything is
right okay
condition on x i and Theta -
1 time y i y of x i summation plus
thet okay
so I think
I I might be making a sign error
somewhere no this one
yeah except I'm missing a y here okay
so this
is you can verify for
yourself that this
is I'm making a sign error
sorry doesn't matter okay module of
science okay don't worry about science
in my lecture you always have to go back
and rederive all the questions for the
science I'm more interested in giving
you
intuitions so what is this
saying you want because this is a convex
function right you know that at
optimality you want to set this gradient
to zero right so when you find the
optimal Theta this gradient will go to
zero okay for a minute ignore this part
for just one minute just ignore this
part assume this is not there then what
does it mean that the gradient goes to
zero this is a vector that's either +
one or minus one so this is going to be
a vector the only way that this gradient
can go to zero can be if this quantity
which is a multiplier
goes to
zero right this is you're summing up
some vectors the Su of the vectors will
go to zero only when these coefficients
go to zero okay so if this if this
coefficient goes to zero what does it
mean it means this coefficient will go
to zero only if P of Yi condition on x i
and Theta goes to
1 right so what does this mean this is
saying
that in logistic regression you're
trying to take the true
label and make its probability as high
as possible ideally you want it to be
one right in if you if you did not have
this regularizer in a maximum likelihood
setting You're simply saying that if you
give me data I'm going to find the
parameter Theta such that for all
positive points the P of y = + 1 is
equal to 1 and for all negative points P
of y = - 1 = 1 right and this is what
I'm going to do and I'm going to try and
find such a Theta once I find that
that's my optimal
solution okay now this is in some sense
a very sort of democratic process so
let's see what let me try to show you
what this means in a
picture since Yi is equ is just + one or
minus one you can visualize this this
conditional distribution right so you
can say what is P of Y condition on X
and Theta how does it look like so at
any X and given a Theta at any X you can
ask okay what is the probability that y
takes on value + one what is the
probability that y takes on value minus
one okay so you can say okay if the
probability that y takes on value one is
this the probability that it takes one
minus one is this right so you can for
any X and Theta you can ask this
question right so and this will you'll
get a something like this in some other
case the arrow may look like that and
like that but you know that these two
the length of these two arrows is going
to add up to one and there only two of
them
okay and what this is telling you is
that logistic regression says I'm going
to try and push the true class if the
true class happens to be minus one I'm
going to push the true class up as much
as I can so that it becomes plus this
becomes one right the height of this
becomes one and here the height becomes
zero okay and then the ver for the other
class
now
intuitively what this means is that in
some sense logistic regression simply
says I'm going to take the true class
and maximize its label okay try try
maximize its probability so I'm going to
make it as high as possible of course
implicitly in there is an argument which
says that how can M this this be of
height one this can be of height one
only if this is of height zero okay so
implicitly in there is an argument which
ISS that you should suppress the
probabilities of the other classes okay
so when you're trying to enhance your
own probability you have to try and
suppress the probability of the other
classes only then you'll get more marks
because you know that the sum of the
probabilities has to add to one okay so
this is an implicit argument this is an
implicit um assum uh sort of condition
in there that you're trying to push the
true label High and the other labels
down okay now some of you may wonder why
do you do this
implicitly I don't need to do this in an
implicit fashion and say oh I want to
push myself up and push the and
therefore implicitly push the other guys
down why don't I directly push the other
guys down so why don't I say I want the
true class to be significantly higher
than everybody
else right which if that happens then
immediately I know that my true class
will have a lot of property
Mass see the argument and we I'll show
you that svms are basically based on
that second
argument so what is happening here
implicitly is that you're trying to say
I don't care about the other classes I'm
going to make my probability High my
true label probability very high in an
svm you say I'm don't only care about
making my true probability High I care
about pushing everybody else down
okay it's like I can climb up only if
others go down here this is like
implicitly I can if there is only a
certain mass in the system I can go up
only if others go down this is an
implicit argument and explicit argument
is what exp okay so that's the so I'll
talk about that we'll talk about we'll
derive svms first in the very
traditional geometric way and then I'll
show you how they related to the
exponential
families
okay so any questions about
this so have you seen any of these kind
of interpretations of logistic
regression
before
good okay now finally I just want to
close this chapter by talking
about why what else can you do with this
with this formulation right so we
specialized it to plus one minus one and
then we understood many things but you
don't have to necessarily specialize it
to plus one minus one it turns out that
even without the specialization this is
still quite powerful and I'll just show
you one
example where sort of if you know this
how to derive this you can basically
derive a classifier for almost any kind
of machine learning problem that you L
more or less I mean there are there are
of course a few exceptions but uh for
any kind of supervised classification
problem you can derive classifiers
okay oh uh and and one more thing I want
to mention I don't know if uh pratique
talked a lot about this but there is one
advantage to logistic regression which
is not there in svms when we talk about
them we'll see that is that the
objective function forvm is not only
convex but it's also
smooth okay so therefore you can apply
certain class of optimizers which you
cannot apply when you are using svms
okay and so you need a separate class of
optimizers for dealing with svm
objectives
okay so let us take this objective
function and I'll very quickly just show
you how to do multiclass classification
with this okay so suppose instead of
just y being + one minus one let's say
you just had the task of optical
character recognition so you you have y
is
say one 0 to 9 okay so you have 10
possible digits you're trying to
recognize digits and now you have a
problem where your labels could be
between 0 to 9 and again you given some
training data each of your uh Yi and the
training data could be between 0 to 9
and now you want to design a classifier
for this setting how do you go around
doing this you do exactly the same thing
as before you crank exactly the same
handle as before the only difference
being that now your G of theta sorry
condition on X looks like log of sum of
J going from 1 0 to 9 of X of 5 of x
i
jorry
XJ *
thet
so now you have to sum over 10 possible
values and again how do you design these
features think of them as questions
right so you can say when the digit is
zero does something happen when the
digit is one does something happen when
the digit is two does something happen
you stack up these questions those are
your
features okay then the Theta is the
weight for the features that's what the
logistic regression is is going to learn
it's going to it's going to learn how
discriminative or how important is a
certain question to answering to
discriminating between different classes
okay that's what the learning procedure
is this is how you compute the log
partition function okay so now given any
problem you can do this but of course as
you can imagine there is no free launch
why is there no free lunch if you cannot
design good questions
then there is nothing to discriminate
right so let me just give you an example
suppose you're trying to divide people
into say whether they come from
different parts of India now if you ask
some relevant features or if you ask
some relevant questions about the about
the features of the people you likely to
be able to distinguish but suppose if I
just simply ask you some random question
about are you interested in photography
right who I mean maybe that is not a
relevant question it does I mean maybe
everybody across all parts of India may
or may not be interested in a certain
hobby or they may or may not be
interested in a certain uh aspect right
but if you just feed those features into
your learning machine into your into
your learning algorithm there is nothing
to distinguish there is no weights to
add there's nothing to distinguish okay
so it's basically garbage in garbage out
if you provide features which you think
can be
discriminative it's likely that you will
learn a good classifier so what so the
right way to
approach logistic regression or in fact
any of these uh other um learning
algorithms is to say I have to ask the
right discriminative questions what this
algorithm is going to help me do is tell
me the relative importance between all
these questions so if you if I feed it
100,000 questions it's going to tell me
that these 10 questions are very
important those 10 questions are you
know reasonably important the other 100
are much much less important and
everything else is CCT right that's the
mind if you approach your learning
problem with this mindset you'll get
much more successful results okay and
this is a general purpose
recipe this is how I just showed you how
you can immediately go to Binary class
you can go to multiclass you can do
multi-label ordinal regression ranking
you name it you can design using the
same framework the only challenge you
have to really face is in all cases the
only challenge is this if your label
space is small enough that you can
compute this summation explicitly your
home there is nothing to do but if your
label space is very large like for
instance if you're doing
ranking okay when you when I give you a
rank a list so in ranking you're given a
list of items and then you're given the
ranking right sort order now the problem
in that case is that this set of all
possible labels is the set of all
possible ways in which you can rank this
list and that is exponentially large
because factorial okay and then the
summation becomes painful and this
Computing this guy becomes painful and
therefore your whole uh optimization
becomes painful okay so in that cases
you have to do other more funny you have
to do other tricks to get around this
okay but if your label space is small
enough that you can do this computation
this is all that you need okay this is
your general purpose
recipe for
computing uh for for coming up with any
classifier okay
question design multic class
classif is it better to have multic
class or train multiple class as one
against all in general what is it's
usually better to do multiclass true
multiclass is easy to do and should be
done it's just that uh again people did
not understand the true um they not
understand uh the connections between uh
between these different classifiers and
so they all started with one versus the
rest and so on in general um you would
never be worse of doing a true
multiclass than doing a one versus the
rest okay
so that's usually the answer that's the
answer also because there is something
about interaction between classes which
you are able to take into account when
you do a true multic class which are not
able to take into account when you're
doing binary one versus rest okay how
much time do we
have okay so we have 10 minutes let
me so any any other questions about
this C you have a question
no
so you understood everything now we'll
ask you to count the the
board let me switch gears a bit and talk
about support Vector machines today
we'll try to do the more geometric
argument and then when we come back on
Thursday I'll show you the probabilistic
argument the same kind of argument that
we did for
um for logistic regression I'll show you
how they are related and again I want to
show you the connections between uh svm
and log regation when we come
back so let's do the geometric argument
today it's sort of simple and I'll only
do the hard margin today and also there
we'll continue with the hard margin and
then we'll do the soft margin as we go
along okay so if I give you a hyp if
suppose I give you some
data so let's say again similar setting
so you're given X1
y1 and so on up
to
X okay so given some data labeled data
and again for the sake of uh Simplicity
plus one minus one labeled okay so I'm
just going to assume for this discussion
that y
i
equals same simple
setting and now we want to find a
classif
okay so that's our goal and we are
interested in finding a linear
classifier okay so um what is what it
means is we are interested in finding a
vector W and a number B okay and I won't
use the arrow all the time but whenever
I write w it's a vector so Vector W and
a b such that this defines a hyper plane
so what does a how does w and B Define a
hyper plane W is the normal vector
and B is the offset so it says how far
away are from the origin so if you
remember your geometry this is the the
hyper plane is the surface that is
perpendicular to W okay so what that
means is that you're looking at w * x +
B is equal to 0 that is this surface
there the hyper plane so w and B Define
this hyper plane
now if I give you any
point okay in space let's call this x i
okay so if I give you any point in
space and if you want to find out what
is the distance of this point to the
hyper plane okay you can do this very El
Elementary geometric argument and I
encourage you to do this once at least
which is you can do this argument and
you can immediately write the
distance to be
this okay so you can say that the
shortest the the perpendicular
distance so this is perpendicular so the
distance between XI and this hyper plane
okay the shortest geodesic that connects
XI to the hyper plane has a has a length
which is given by this and there a this
is a very this a purely geometric
argument you can make this argument at
least once you should do it and it's
it's good to try Okay so this is is
nothing but the
distance of x i okay we also going to
call this the margin okay so margin as
in how far away is Xi from this decision
hyper
plan okay so we'll also use the term
margin
okay
now if you look at this argument and if
you look at how W and B are defining
this hyper plane okay there is one
slight catch okay if you pay attention
you'll see that catch the catch is the
following if I take any nonzero
Alpha and multiply both W and B with
that
Alpha
okay this also defines exactly the same
hyper plan remember this is the equation
right so if I just multiply this by
Alpha and Alpha nothing
changes okay so Alpha W and Alpha * B
also Define the same hyper plane the
same
surface and this is a problem right so
there's an identifiability
issue I could give you one W and B and
somebody else can give you the same W
and B with a scaling Factor Alpha and
you will not be able to distinguish
between them because they both Define
the same hyper
plan okay that point clear I see blank
faces
so if I multiply W and B by a scaling
Factor the surface that I get if I look
at this w x + b or Alpha WX + B if I
look at the set of all X right such that
this condition is satisfied this is the
hyper plane right if I multiply
everything by Alpha this set is the same
as
this
so therefore there's an identifiability
issue if you want to identify this
plane by using W and B you have a
problem okay so to get around this
problem what I'm going to do is I'm
going to enforce the following condition
I'm just going to
say w
doxi + b the minan over I going from 1
to M I'm just going to orbitally set it
to one doesn't matter I could set it to
42 nobody will care okay but I just want
to set it to some constant in this case
I just choose the constant one but it
doesn't have to
be once I do this you can immediately
see that this scaling is
fixed why because if I take W and B If I
multiply them by Alpha then this
becomes this right and this is not if
this was equal to one then this is equal
to Alpha mod
Alpha correct so the scaling is
immediately fixed do you see that I
cannot scale W and B by an arbitary
number because if I scale them by an
arbitrary number this minan would no
longer be one the mean would be
Alpha correct so the scaling is fixed so
there has to be exactly one W and B for
which this is satisfied any scaling of
them
this will not be satisfied this
condition will not be
satisfied
okay so once I fix this scaling in this
way then what
happens I can ask if I give you a set of
points X1 to XM that are given to me I
can ask what is the minimum margin so
what does it mean by the minimum margin
I'm saying there are all these points
lying here find me the closest
point okay so the closest point simply
is because we know this is the distance
of the ith point I'm just going to do
this
is margin for the entire data set so I'm
going to say for this set of points in
this set of points what is the closest
point and now because I have fixed this
scaling to be equal to one my margin is
simply going to be because this quantity
the mean is fixed to be equal to one my
Marg margin is
simply minan
over 1
over n right so this is my my so I don't
need the mean anymore and this is going
to be my
margin
okay that clear so just to recap any
hyper plane is defined by a weight by a
normal and and offset but there is a
identifiability problem which is you can
scale your normal and offset by constant
factor and you will not be able to
distinguish the two the hyper planes
because they're exactly the same to fix
this what we are going to do is we're
going to orbitally set this we're going
to say if I give if you give me some
data I'm going to orbitally set that the
mean of w.x a plus b equals 1 for this
particular data okay once you do this
the identifiability issue is fixed and
then you can ask find for me the point
which is the closest or how far away is
the is the closest point of this Cloud
how far away is it from my hyper plane
that you can immediately write it as 1/
the norm of w the two nor of w okay and
this is called the margin so basically
what you're asking is how far away is
the closest point oh out of time
okay so um how far away is the Clos
point from this Cloud to the hyper plane
the answer is it's 1 / nor of w okay so
next time we'll use this to derive a
classifier and then we'll talk about
Connections to exponential families
okay questions this is a geometric
argument you need to look it up and work
it out once on your own so please please
work this out once before you come then
you'll be able to
um you know you'll be able to enjoy the
lecture better so do this before you
come it won't be very
hard
okay thank
you each here Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available